[Musique]
la ministre de la transition écologique
barbara pompili s'est rendu à trappes
dans l'un des entrepôts de l'entreprise
métro le site est équipé de panneaux
photovoltaïques depuis 2019 ces derniers
seront bientôt obligatoire cela fait
partie des dix mesures annoncées par la
ministre de la transition écologique
pour le développement du photovoltaïque
le méga centres de vaccination au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
réduit ses effectifs il passe d'environ
3000 vaccinations par jour à 300 ce
nouveau mini centre composé de trois
boxes avec deux médecins et une
infirmière est ouvert du lundi au
vendredi de 9h à 15h la trêve hivernale
a commencé une période durant laquelle
les locataires ne peuvent pas être
expulsés de leur logement jusqu'au 31
mars 2022 cependant les personnes
concernées par cette trêve doivent tout
de même payer une indemnité qui équivaut
au montant du loyer et des charges un
nouveau pôle périnatale ouvre ses portes
au dessus de la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines au total quatorze
professionnels seront présents pour
répondre aux besoins de la femme
enceinte et des enfants jusqu'à l'âge de
1 an enfin l'open de france est de
retour au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une reprise
attendue suite aux annulations de ces
deux dernières années à cause du coc
vite 19 le tournoi se disputera du 22 au
25 septembre 2022
[Musique]
pas